hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H foe
everybody out there welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is ru garbage I am your host stage
Foley coming at ya from beautiful story
of Queens where the bodies are stacking
hi folks not gonna lie Tia a little
dicey in the neighborhood this time of
the year
my co-host coming to you from an
undisclosed location somewhere in the
southern realm of New Jersey ladies and
gentlemen Kevin James Ryan hey what's up
king of the boardwalk down here baby got
it all over myself all day long
funnel cake Boulevard sitting pretty
down there just doing loops on the
rollercoasters you know I'm happy to be
here guys thanks so much for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on iTunes
pull video available on YouTube Spotify
all that good stuff we appreciate the
support so far Thank You Kippy and gang
we got a very special guest today we
gotta get we got a celebrity in the
building the originator of podcasting in
New York I'll say his kids a trendsetter
guys we [ __ ] podcasts she's also a
best-selling author and she has a brand
new project out right now that you can
check out called well ladies and
gentlemen you know where you love her
Christina Hutchinson everybody we
appreciate having you here and you got
your little buddy Kevin next to you a
little puppy doggy yeah I just wanted to
bring the dog out so I can talk baby
talking annoyed Kevin is my Kevin hates
them at the odd look at that no belly
it says I'm in a 3-person zoom and I'm
not even the cutest Kevin that is that
[ __ ] break right there oh man if
you know reminiscent of childhood I
don't know what is weird where does the
name Kevin come from sometimes that
could be a garbage trait why people name
their dogs and what they name their dogs
right so are we just nosy [ __ ] in the
corner get that later don't worry about
that
I'll obsessed with dogs that have human
names I think it's really funny
and like I've wanted a dog for a long
time and Kevin was always a potential
name his middle name is McAlister and
it's licensing so I didn't realize that
somebody pointed out the same initials
um but yeah Kevin McCallister from home
alone
gotcha fair enough that's a good one
love me unconditionally and I mean Julia
that's crazy lady stuff I like to funny
well thank you so much for doing the
show we know a little bit about each
other as far as like you kinda I think
grew up near where Kevin and I are from
yeah yeah I'm from bucks
yeah box so I was yeah yeah not too far
from Doyle's town i nodi town quite well
so high school I went to Council Rock Oh
fair enough your football team was a but
you know they were good I guess but they
were mean yeah I don't know was council
rock at rossini West or something when I
was in high school they were both
garbage back then man those kids along I
remember one of them one of the ones up
by you I don't even know I just remember
I'm like those guys look like farmers
like they would like show up in like
jeans and and flannels and [ __ ] like
when that wasn't in style I'm like you
know these guys look like construction
workers they're gonna [ __ ] us up yeah
it's my school district was huge we had
1,100 people my graduating class so it
had it had chunks of farmer kids chunks
of like really rich kids and giant
mansion houses and then the poor's condo
with my mom so I thought you went too
and this is inside baseball so we
apologize people aren't from the
Delaware Valley area but I always
thought you grew up in hatboro wasn't
wasn't
hatboro connection yeah I was in your
hat bro hatboro was a neighboring town
yeah I think yeah Pearl was Penndel and
they went to our high school a pepper I
went to North Penn but I I I went to
high school at North Penn and I grew up
born into his town but like had my
formative years in Virginia and then
moved to where I moved to Lansdale so
that's kind of you know so that's why
you went to North Bank you lived in
Lansdale all right so I was literally
next door in Bluebell yeah oh yeah I was
shaken yeah you know what two lives up
Catholic if we had a little scratch
buddy I took a couple of classes there
what did you take classes there too
no but I should fully has a cafeteria
named after the East Wing but now like
what you're saying is yeah all those
towns out there they got like more rural
as they got away from the city well you
know like kids from solder tin with the
ones that I was like one of these guys
made a [ __ ] corn they were like
hillbillies well it was like you got
further out so it was more and more
rural like so like chunks of that were
not developed at all and chunks were
like yeah we raise livestock there's a
lot of meat yeah there's a lot of meat
up in that way which is always a weird
thing I love this we're all in the same
circle so I'm staying right off the bat
hutch you gotta be garbage that is that
is PA trash if I've ever seen it a
[ __ ] wah-wah a - that's a first
how do you feel about rita's water ice
oh he's a water ice
you can't not be from Philly and not be
garbage I don't know anybody that
doesn't have it's funny I got my I'm
sorry go I was it's a billy trash is my
favorite type of person it really is me
I love it I love all of my uncles
they're all like plumber they're all
construction workers and one like I have
my brother who like thinks he's not
garbage but I'm like dude you it's like
he went to he went to private school
they're like dude come on you're a
[ __ ] trash you're throwing through
you can't you went to private corn you
didn't yes yes or no irony he went to a
pen charter which is like a really good
really nice school I don't know I could
have yeah I think I don't know was
really I didn't know anybody with the
pump I grew up going to public school
and then he did he's he had jumped
around a little bit
whatever yeah I just all my friends I
had to I was like I don't to leave my
[ __ ] friends and go make new friends
that's a weird thing that's a garbage
move - I always thought that was strange
when two siblings didn't go to the same
school yeah usually behavioral reasons
someone got kicked out or something you
know what if that's why one's a comedian
and one's a what does he do what he's a
business owner like it is like he does
he does well for himself that's good
yeah privacy what education pays off you
know what I mean yeah I'll just say
maybe regrettin you're like my Council
Rock South [ __ ] don't diploma I got
Christina did you have brothers and
sisters growing up or was she just you
and your mom I have an older brother
he's me and my parents my parents they
split up for three years but they other
than that they're still together yes
split up and got back together that's
[ __ ] crazy
what do they get divorce that is [ __ ]
crazy I love daddy they never got
officially divorced they separated when
I was 10 or 11 and that's why I moved
from Chesapeake Virginia it's my dad's
in the Navy so we were stationed
stationed there and I moved with my mom
to Pennsylvania because I was born so we
went back there and then my dad would
send my mom books of poetry which was
very unlike him now it's like he's
trying real hard and then they got back
together and they're doing great
and did he move up - he obviously moved
up to Philly with you guys exactly yeah
he moved back up to Philly and now they
live in Ocean City New Jersey
so that's some like I'm fine I was just
in Ocean City the other
in Wildwood right now my Merrill mind if
my mom joined a Facebook group about
whether or not they should open the
boardwalks or close them in Ocean City
specifically and she calls me every day
with like the current drama yeah like
she's like get these Outsiders out of
here we don't want them here boardwalks
should be for permanent residents oh my
god
yeah I know yeah so for the listener
there's these like small short towns in
Jersey that everybody from all filling
trash it's I don't know you don't even
have to have somebody you don't even
have to have money like you got anybody
it's like anybody can buy a house
anywhere from plumbers to doctors like
you don't need that much you can buy
these you can buy a shore house in these
little towns so they're all second home
owners and now so when the corona hit
that's what I did I'm like I'm getting
the [ __ ] out of New York
like I've been down here for three weeks
just hanging out but everybody that
lives here hates the [ __ ] out of us like
I like reverse my car in so they can't
see my Pennsylvania license plate and
stuff and they don't want any Outsiders
here yeah cuz there's like there's maybe
twelve permanent residents in Ocean City
I mean not a lot like my parents are one
of those permanent residents and she's
pissed but I'm like mommy this was your
second home you'd be there so yeah they
want it so the locals want to keep the
boardwalks close but the people that are
that are second homes that are down
there and stuck down there they're like
[ __ ] it we got the kids get [ __ ]
Gilliam's water Peter [ __ ] it open so we
can it shotgun Falls exactly well the
locals want to keep the beaches open
just for the locals yeah dude
she's like well they should just ask to
see our paperwork I'm like mom that's
not she wants to set up customs at the
[ __ ] at the bridge
oh my god that's good stuff well let's
give this some questions here so just so
I have a picture and I know what I'm
dealing with as far as like high school
is concerned you grew up in North Penn
school district in southeastern
Pennsylvania correct all right all right
just so I have an idea and your brother
didn't really grow up with you cuz he
was eight years older you when you were
when you were born he was eight yeah
okay all right I'm gonna I mean we're
about your were cut from the same cloth
you're Bucks County trash I got you
oh yeah I got your [ __ ] pegged for it
I love it I love it cuz I remember I
mean we were garbage in Bluebell but we
used to I used to look at like North
Penn and like those schools that were
out further like like yeah these [ __ ]
trashy farmer Killick miss Acton oh my
god miss acted I don't even know what
that is but it sounds bad yeah a lot I
am breathing out there my mom and I used
to baby my mommy's a babysit she do all
these odd jobs when she was separated
for my dad she would clean houses
babysit and we babysat this family lived
in Bluebell and they lived in the oh my
god their house was gorgeous that was
like giant houses for me Bluebell was
always really fancy yeah but here's the
thing you haven't you haven't been
through the Foley residence I'll pay you
that much
it ain't that fancy there was a part of
artsy it's it's the same thing you would
see you'd set a couple minutes ago that
like it's for some reason our area that
whole entire area down there is such a
mix of like blue-collar neighborhoods
that were there from like the 50's like
the original neighborhoods that were
built in there and then you have these
neighborhoods that got put up in the 80s
and the 90s now I have all the
McMansions and stuff like that and then
there's even another [ __ ] tear like
the guy that owns us healthcare used to
live like right in Bluebell he had like
mansions and if you start going out
towards like where Germantown Academy is
it's like it's like real actual wealth
Zacks like all [ __ ] mixed in and it's
so weird
we're we're in the the lower tiers to be
in the poor part of your town yeah I was
a specific one of the sense that like my
dad got some money at like I mean we
grew up there grew up poor but like he
got some money in the 90s and built a
McMansion and then we couldn't afford it
like three years later so so we were
still in it but it was just like there
wasn't money like we had like an
unfinished shed and like you know food
it was I would have to cut the grass
which was fine but like it would just be
like you know like lawn company's
cutting everybody else's grass it was
all like some South American guys and
then me like go over you know furniture
house this a refrigerator box
you're still trying to keep it up act in
San C with a polo shirt on yes the
furniture is on layaway when we first
got down to Philly we had it we moved
into like a townhouse community oh yeah
right and like it was great like when I
look back in and out it was awesome but
for some reason all the kids liked that
I was friends do all had that stigma
that we were living in in a townhouse
community and like the other kids all at
houses my one buddy got a lover man he
used to say every couple of months that
his family was moving out it was like a
dog at the SPCA it was like a dog at the
SPCA he's kept saying I know there's
like kids at the adoption agency like
today he's gonna be the day we're moving
out man I remember one time we rode
bikes to like one of the McMansion
neighborhoods and he was showing us a
house saying like I think that's the one
my mom bought nice you're still living
there today man that's heartbreaking
trying to get out baby like a Bruce
Springsteen song
now he's town house people throw and
throw like at that same amount of spaces
in New York they build a task
development by Montgomery Mall and it
was just like divorced dads and stuff
and we used to make fun of the kids who
live in town houses but it was a lot of
property it was a big home sure but
because it was connected to other homes
were like you're poor I know the I know
the exact townhouse community you're
talking about yeah yeah exactly what
you're talking well when my parents got
to my parents got divorced we moved like
my dad moved he moved out of like the
you know that McMansion or whatever and
into like not even a tent like in a
proper apartment like over by neshaminy
mall which was parks in the suburbs man
there's only like nine of them
apartments in the suburbs are tough look
as a guy who opened the door and I was
like take me back to Mom's house no go
back there tell her you're sorry I don't
know get some roses kitchen
Oh whatever the [ __ ] you gotta do but
we're out of here yeah right some
[ __ ] but yeah that's funny man cheese
what does your dad do in the Navy just
sounds decide um he was a chief he was a
chief petty officers
which is like I guess the highest-ranked
you can get without a college degree he
was drafted when he was 18 he passed
letter a week before he got his college
acceptance letter and so it had been
reversed he wouldn't have had to serve
he stayed on and what did he actually do
in the Navy do you know um he were
paired he worked on the aircraft
carriers repaired jet planes and okay he
was stationed he went to China a lot
he went to uh Japan and worked on the US
bases there the US Navy bases and fix
the airplane so he was in Nam yeah yeah
he didn't he wasn't like front lines or
anything he was a mechanic but then he
became chief I don't really know what
you do it I don't know it's funny like I
really asked my dad like what
specifically did you that's good you
know Mike coincidentally why I'm asking
my dad retired chief petty officer
United States Navy oh [ __ ] in 26 years
served UNAM and the last place she was
stationed was Willow Grove Air Base oh
my dad my dad was in Willowbrook when I
was boarded the was tell me dad wait
wait what's your this what's your dad's
name
Terry Foley Terry Foley does anybody
know my dad sorry
Sione does he only you guys money what
was your hippie dad doing during the war
Kippy huh smoking grass and hanging out
probably my dad used to get perms - I
just saw a picture my daddy's homes
I got burns my dad I mean my I don't
know if men did my dad did for sure he
loved it I think the big truck head and
he had a big thing I don't know an afro
I think he used to do a lot of narcotics
back in the day nice they don't want to
hear no lamppost I want to get one now I
want to get a perm now and I had a perm
when I was a kid
cuz all my cousin huh I had a perm I was
a little fat nine-year-old kid playing
soccer and I had this huge head I like
Jackie moon I had this chemically curled
with a part I got my mom chemically
curled my hair with a perm because all
my older cousins they all were tall and
they all had curly hair and the reason
that I did it is our garb
I am your adopted father so it's not you
know the worst thing that can happen to
somebody it's too funny do ya just read
me babe just recently like so wait what
happened I missed it
I got it my mom was adopted when so I
got it 23 meet kids for my parents one
Christmas and then I did it I had a girl
messaged me saying she was my half
sister and I asked my mom about it and
that's when I found out I was a sperm
donor baby
dad's not my biological father but you
know I wish I was related to him he's
very handsome and well my brother always
the mailman's baby my whole life because
I don't look like him holy [ __ ] I called
him one day I'm like yo DJ you weren't
wrong did you know he had no idea oh man
he's got to feel like [ __ ] do the same
thing happen the same thing happened to
my mom someone somebody she did I told
them I was the first of all not 23andme
stuff all that stuff I think it's
garbage
well they can only tell you bad news
it's a bit like leave it it's never like
holy [ __ ] you got a million dollars
waiting for you so you're susceptible to
you parents like your parents go on yeah
everybody just does it just to be trying
to be bougie and [ __ ] like that but my
my brother and my mom gave each other
one for Christmas like two years ago and
I was like God don't do it bad idea next
thing you know six months later my mom's
getting an email hey I think I think
you're my half-sister why not find out
maybe my grandfather isn't really my
grandfather and that my grandma was
[ __ ] steppin out on the town nice I
get an email once a month from 23 me
it's like you have between 9 and 12 new
DNA relatives because multiple where not
to me
and a bunch of them were sperm donor
babies but one of them was actually
raised by the man who donated the sperm
but every yeah every every month or so
I'll get Brandon
half-brothers and half-sisters that's
crazy I have so what I don't think I
don't have no desire to do that I'm from
a huge high my mom's one of nine so I
have 32 first cousins on the one side
this guy's garbage enough so it's like
I'm like I have I have cousins that I
know that I'm like that I don't need I
don't talk to so I don't need to add any
more people to that yeah I don't have
any I don't have I just thought I got a
very small family but now alright let's
get into the game here you're giving a
lot away but I love it Kippy you want to
lead off with some questions I got one
cuz we talked about it where you brought
it up briefly when was it last time you
were at a water park Gilliam's Gilliam's
right on the boardwalk at Ocean City
baby
yes that's right the last one has a
water purpose probably about a year ago
the mall that's not that long ago to be
honest with [ __ ] love water birth
actually the last water clerking when
she was at Six Flags oh that's a tough
one do the Six Flags water park is a
tough water park it was a day of
thunderstorms and so no one was out and
so we kind of had the water park to
ourselves it was really nice I thought
they're fun but they oh man they can be
a bit trashy from time to time amusement
parks or trashy and garbage but if you
catch like great if you get you can get
in great adventure on an off day and
there's nobody in there it's totally
[ __ ] worth it
yep roller coaster [ __ ] kick-ass yeah
go with someone in a wheelchair or go on
Memorial Day not wait in a line it's
true
Kip I just has to be throwing up did you
ever spend time hanging out in the
parking lot of a Wawa 7 or 11 or a gas
station oh my god yeah I still hang out
in parking lots of Wawa did you drive to
school we went did you drive to school
drive to North Penn yep senior year I
did smoking cigarettes I didn't touch
cigarettes or weed until after I
graduate high school to play sporting
huh did you play sports in high school
in
school high school I was a theater nerd
okay alright I later heard that scores
you some points very aristocratic I took
it that adds a couple that did ups a
couple of garbage points for sure
definitely it takes a couple points off
theater very sophisticated I like it
let's uh let's take it back I want to
know a little bit about the holidays at
your house number one did you have
colored light did you celebrate
Christmas or Hanukkah Christmas did you
have colored lights on the tree no we're
not that trashy thank God great white
lights all the way or you're [ __ ]
garbage here
oh man color lights are a tough [ __ ]
luck man oh yeah and the reason I wanted
to ask this is because one of our
listeners Gunners lost he sends in a lot
of questions he wanted to know did you
have eggnog around the holidays yes I've
actually never tried eggnog but my
family is obsessed with eggnog and
whiskey so that's that's trashy but [ __ ]
heaven it's awesome you Kevin you never
had egg nog right nobody [ __ ] to it no
we used to do these things called nutty
Irishmen it was like Kahlua vodka and
Bailey's maybe no I remember a time in
the 80s when when my family thought
Kahlua was like the [ __ ] Fountain of
Youth through to that fruit of the gods
dude that was like diamonds and pearls
to people in the [ __ ] in the midday Z
oh my god they got a bottle of Kahlua
yeah [ __ ] trash yeah eggnog is garbage
but it's awesome and I'll tell you does
it make who doesn't make a bad one if
you stop over to that wild war around
the holidays people without a mean mean
ugh wha-wha chocolate milk
milkshakes they have those machines
we're [ __ ] saw wow it's just a great
establishment shout out to mr. mrs. Wawa
down there yeah time when that milkshake
machine when you know the one were you
pulling out of the freezer and you put
it in and it makes it man that [ __ ]
that blew my mind ma'am
all right I got one growing up did your
mom used to use like Cool Whip
containers as Tupperware or like
anywhere the rest Tupperware no she
actually didn't classy that's pointed
but now she did not there was one or two
times where I opened up the water of
thinking it was butter and it was like
gravy or something oh my god
surprise [ __ ] yeah what about
the Hawaiian pizzas that's something
that you would eat oh my god
Hawaiian pizza from Pizza Hut pizza up a
say hey I didn't say anything about the
buffet meets up buffet
[ __ ] forget about it that is a class
that [ __ ] was awesome all those buffets
back in the eighties have you already
member of your family ever been a member
of a studio audience I have yeah
decently are back in the day oh the bean
high school I got I found I felt very
special but I found it anybody could get
that to TRL I was a tiara I mean that's
a get back in the day that's how I felt
so cool the only pass you get is double
dare that's the only pass I can give you
TRL is pretty close
no TRL's not tracked to TRL so you're
older yo do TRL was [ __ ] I mean that
that was the biggest show in the world
it's a time for kid that's you just want
to be a couple
yeah that's great what's that Punk's
name that ran it Carson Daly oh yeah oh
man that's too funny okay does anybody
in your family play scratch-off lottery
tickets I do do you ever win anything
big I have won so many times so my
favorite scratch off the only kind I get
is the crossword puzzle sprite
and they come in variables of $3 $2 $5
$10 and 21 of the other things I love
about hua was they have a lot of lottery
ticket machines but yeah I've won a
hundred bucks a couple times like I've
yeah and the scratch off crossword
puzzles really make you feel like you're
about to win and they're so addicting
mm-hmm they're so addictive once you
once you hit a dollar I'll stop at the
place right near New York Comedy Club on
24th Street get the dollar once if I win
a free I get a dollar I'm back over
there and I haven't gotten a birthday
card since I was 9 years old that didn't
have a couple of [ __ ] scratch offs in
it yeah you want it you want to hear
something real trash was some time
there's a couple times where just edad
she's the one who got me hooked on these
scratch-off crossword puzzles back in
the day we still like popping adderall
just furiously scratch these crossword
puzzles and there's a deli right by me
and we would keep winning so we will buy
the amount of tickets for the amount of
money that we won oh my god it was so
much fun I wish I could say I mean we
get on we get on Christmas like we get
like big packs of them oh yeah my family
would have tournaments on Christmas cuz
my dad had one of those bait like
mancave basements and one of the top
prizes was a tree that had like clips on
it and my mom like put all these a lot
like hundreds of lotto tickets
you guys remember did you guys go
through the phase there was a phase of
my family where I'm like people's
anniversary they would get money trees
they would get like a bouquet of flowers
that was made out of bills yeah yeah one
time we did that for instead of the
lotto ticket tree we did a month no
sense to me
yeah don't do like 100 in that did you
have any tri-colored popcorn in your
house growing up never but I was
obsessed with popcorn
and I ate it pretty much every day I ate
a bag of microwave popcorn every day to
the point where I'd go to st. John's ha
John Hopkins hospital for like 12 hours
once when I was in college to get all
these tests because my test
we're so [ __ ] up oh my god I ate too
much microwave popcorn yeah that's not
good holy [ __ ] that's my color no
tricolor okay have you ever gone to a
Caribbean island and come back with
cornrows in your hair with braids no no
no I see we oppose this I'm shocked most
of the female listeners just because
obviously the longer hair but and they
all say no but back in the day every I
feel like every girl to Jamaica came
back yeah for like a couple weeks one
side of their head and cornrows in it
yeah high school I didn't go on a
vacation until my first ever vacation
I've ever been on because when I was a
kid we always just went to visit
relatives so that was it wasn't really
you never went on a proper vacation but
my first ever vacation was five years
ago so so just go to a place that's
gonna go anybody and just to go wow did
you get cornrows in your hair then all
right do any of the male members of your
family uncles cousins father have a
ponytail no okay no my brother grew his
hair long once but that's good and to
donate it oh there you go yeah I guess
you get a ponytail for a brief amount of
time but that was for the purpose that
yeah that's anti garbage that's yeah
yeah that's a wholesome move right there
and also do any of them wear cowboy
boots yeah it's a big one no no but we
do go to NASCAR races you don't think
that was something that we wanted to
know are you [ __ ] with yeah oh man
that's tough my stepdad big cowboy boot
guy big NASCAR guy yes
I'll tell you what it's garbage but I'm
doing I see that infield where they
thing on all the [ __ ] trucks and it's
off that up that looks like a good time
man you know in the Richmond Virginia
track is the shortest track I know too
much about my brother
car so I know how to fix cars and [ __ ]
but the NASCAR track is only
three-quarters of a mile short of track
and in the NASCAR races and there's a
lot of crashes so it's very it's
actually very entertaining yeah
did you ever all this do you ever grow
up good you ever go to Flemington there
used to be a racetrack in Flemington New
Jersey
oh no we go to my set that you this is
how trashy I am myself that I used to
race cars actually sounds really trashy
no we used took at least you gotta
Flemington New Jersey no is it started
out as dirt track and then it you know
whatever they paved it I guess they got
enough a couple of bucks shaved it and
then we would go like Fridays and he
would race and he would crash every time
and then law [ __ ] been like a month
fixing the car it was just your mom
married Ricky Bobby
yeah it stopped man all right miss
Hutchinson yeah have you ever collected
any of the following
numbnuts know Chinese star no what about
beanie babies bustin cold my parents had
a collectible toy store they graduated
from selling things at a flea market
table to having a store after my dad
retired he had like took him a while to
figure out a job that he liked and and
while we had the collectible toy store
when the beanie baby craze was was
everywhere my mom would make me go into
stores to buy all she would give me
hundreds of dollars and I would have to
buy all the beanie babies because they
were they weren't letting people to
resell them because they were worth more
than you were buying them for at the
store and I remember when the McDonald's
had mini beanie babies in their happy
meals I was probably about six or seven
my parents would go through the
McDonald's drive-thru at twenty Happy
Meals just for the toys so I would eat
McDonald's first straight up six months
oh my god that is a new level I didn't
think I thought you were garbage this is
a hole I mean the garbage you did did
you ever go to the Mart this is inside
baseball game would you ever go to the
the Montgomeryville mark
no or the Montgomerys wolf there was a
flea market up by the montgomery film
all well luckily by the time I moved
back to Pennsylvania they were past that
that was the end of this collectible
toys face Wow man 20 happy news you
would think as a kid that would be like
a dream come true come true for you now
what are you talking about
like reheat like Cole's McDonald's
doesn't fly no no oh they would take it
home and like put it in the refrigerator
and then like dish them out like that
yeah call child services on you now if
you did something like wow that's
[ __ ] crazy all right another one
growing up did you ever make Tang or
country time lemonade I'm a country time
my grandmother who had suffered a stroke
because she'd spaghetti and butter all
day I know some white-trash [ __ ] we have
buttered noodles all time they're also
peanut butter and butter sandwiches but
not even real butter
Country Crock oh man that big that big
tan thing a country got yeah that's
pretty good
oh where I grew up I was born in
wilkes-barre Pennsylvania and up there
it was always the thing that when you
made a sandwich like you made like a ham
and cheese sandwich there was bought it
you buttered the bread it was almost
butter but you didn't like like a like
it wasn't grilled though cuz I know well
crazy brother cold I'm saying you just
borrow babies that make my skin crawl
dude that's girls okay peanut butter and
butter Oh God it was so good I'm telling
you it's unbelievable
did you guys ever eat steak UM's what I
had them with in the quarantine I've had
steak that's why I bought them Adam
because I'm down here I'm down in
Wildwood so is that the I was at the
Acme and I went and as they had steak
Holmes and my girl is my girl my wife
she's from Europe so I was
trying to explain what they were so I
just bought them and it's literally it's
paper meat it's like paper meat it
crumbles in your hand it's so well I
didn't realize you're supposed to like
chop it up to make out the cheesesteaks
honey thing my dad didn't do that we
just had sheets of meat slices on white
bread yeah dude oh that's the way to do
it just like that with maybe a little
maybe a slice of crush for a crash
single on there a little bit of [ __ ]
ketchup in business slapper cool a
jammer and that makes me [ __ ] reeks
so that brings me that brings me to my
next question were you a juice box or a
Capri Sun house all the growing up Oh
money bags over what good this hippy
Capri Suns yeah that's a good idea
we never got a Capri Sun our highest pay
grade was a high see you guys might be
too young you remember my dad still buys
I seize the fruit punch and the orange I
was an orange guy to be honest with
those I remember we used to get it in a
can
they had to use a can of that he had to
open two things it was a good tomato
sauce can they come yeah they used to
sell them back in the day like that they
used to buy juices like that and a big
man like it would be like a foot high
and it was probably like you know four
inches wider when I was like a huge soup
can and you would have to open it and it
would go glug right out of the [ __ ]
can we we used to buy like frozen Julie
cans like lemonade or yeah I was gonna
ask thinking the next week's guest that
that's so high they don't they had to
stop making that stuff too concentrated
for now it's still out there it's told
me don't make it we've just evolved my
my name's to mention that up with a
[ __ ] wooden spoon yeah that was not
something you could do in a pinch that
you had if you were thirsty you were
gonna die in it you know what I used to
do that my mom used to get so mad at she
would go into there freeze
to pull one out to make juice and like
half of it would be gone because I would
go and eat it concentrated slushie yeah
it's [ __ ] awesome that's like that's
like coke straight from Columbia never
stopping good [ __ ] yeah Wow Foley's so
doing this podcast so many I mean you
learn a lot about each other you learn a
lot and I mean the reasons why you are
the size that you are are frozen
concentrated orange juice and when I was
a kid there was two places that I wanted
to live in fantasy I wanted to live in a
country time lemonade commercial ah cuz
remember how awesome that place looked
the old guys sit on the porch chillin
kids riding their bikes down the field I
wanted to live there and I wanted to
live in Hidden Valley oh my god I won't
lie I was at the good during the corona
pandemic okay you're in you're taking
your life in your hands and you go to
the grocery store I was in the grocery
store for like 15 minutes where I
wouldn't budge because I couldn't find
Hidden Valley Ranch because I won't get
anything else but if it aint Hidden
Valley take that yeah I hear you make it
to the bank ever played darts got a
Biagio holy [ __ ] I pegged myself as
quite a piece of garbage and I only had
one when I was in college
oh I had one growing up I have Michael I
used to go to fat black pussycat all the
time to play darts I was like my
favorite spot to play darts darts is so
fun though couple of beers and throw the
[ __ ] darts around a little bit forget
it
isn't it crazy that they're allowed to
have that though in a place where people
are drinking yeah absolutely it's it's
yeah it makes you wonder you know they
really put a lot of trust in people I've
you on ax throwing they let you drink
there too I look at that [ __ ] and I'm
like are you [ __ ] kidding me
and I got stoned one Dan Soder and I got
stone once and went to throw axes so I'm
like this [ __ ] not allowing that's
[ __ ] that's insane I would you ever
see like you see the videos of them like
bouncing back and flying at the people
all right I got another one did you I
got two that they're in semi reference
to Foley growing up - do we have milk
for dinner yeah that's two for two I
believe on guests yeah I don't know
that's he thinks that's a real trashy
thing I think so they were classy so I I
think I think that knows no economic
balance know you milk for dinner is
trash you've never been to the [ __ ]
you know you've never been to Del
Frisco's or the Capital Grille got a
t-bone and a [ __ ] glass of 2% it
doesn't happen oh man milk for dinner
that's tough yeah yeah holy [ __ ] I did
not see it going this way honestly I
mean like I did not see it going this
way I feel oh man you leaned into it I
love it I [ __ ] love it your mom ever
make meat loaf
oh yeah nice so that's there you go have
you ever owned a jet ski no ever owned a
jet ski
no ever soul jet skis yes on a jet ski
once and it was terrifying ma'am is
there any three liters of soda in your
house growing up as a kid oh my god yes
[Laughter]
brand - and cereal in the bag oh yeah oh
yeah so embarrassed by that like dad
we're not poor he's like we kind of are
relaxed sometimes sometimes let me tell
you something as an expert on this all
right sometimes the cereal in the bag
some types were better than the regular
ones
no way no some of them were better I was
so embarrassed that we are a household
that had
Cyril I don't know where I got this from
though but I was humiliating for
whatever stupid-ass reason yeah well
it's different than what everybody else
has that's the thing you know so you're
like this isn't what you see in the
commercials
they're not you know they're not they're
not advertising you know chocolate O's
or whatever commercials only the Lemur
so did but sometimes you ever I would go
over places like friend's house who
would do bag cereal and they would put
it in like a Tupperware container yes
that's not that's [ __ ] sitcom [ __ ]
right there
we used to get it wasn't in a bag but it
was it was off-brand and we always got
it it was it was an off-brand Frosted
Flakes and that was one it was like
Special K was so [ __ ] shitty I love
Special K dude loved it I remember one
time I went to frosted flakes we didn't
have it I'm like remember like fighting
with my mom and she just took Special K
and put sugar just sprinkled it on I was
like hey we can do this all day long
I'd rather have that you know what
sucked - we always God you guys ever get
Kix cereal oh my god kicks yes those
things you like the kiss Golden Grahams
come on Golden Grahams is awesome you
tell us crunch you know you're talking
to high dollar items you know what I saw
recently that I forgot but I they had a
french toast crunch do you remember that
short-lived I was never allowed to get
the cookie crisp but I'm like yeah
crunch it's the same [ __ ] my mom's the
same rules say only three kids got
cookie crisps nobody got cookie krisp
yeah your parents needed you or they
didn't want to discipline you or they
like didn't have time for you yeah yeah
cookie Chris lived up to the hype tower
when I got into like high school in
college I start applying it on my own
[ __ ] not too shabby
you know you know what was pretty bad
too I did say I don't know if it's a
trashy or you know a fad thing because I
was a fat kid we would make cereal out
of Teddy Grahams
it's more like a student float in milk I
don't know
look I just it just popped it in my head
that we would do that I don't think my
mom co-signed it I think that my brother
type thing
Thanks when you got to the bottom of
that that milk and a couple s Teddy
Grahams oh all right I think I only got
one or two more here did ya did you have
a garage fridge at any point in your
life yeah we had a garage fridge and
freezer love a garage fridge man that oh
yeah people are starting to comment and
stuff they say there are only one one
fridge people like oh my god I think I
never thought about how weird a garage
fridge is actually it's great you talk
about this all the time I think we were
talking about it Corinne I think it was
kirinda didn't have one maybe and we
were like yeah it's never like you know
whatever buys two fridges it's not
working
it's like leftover or you felt it's over
there oh yeah exactly and uncle was
getting rid of a fridge and you're like
I will put it in here yeah yeah that's
my final question is have you ever
gotten your blood pressure taken at a
CVS yeah I Got News for You kid you're
garbage man talk about the nail in the
coffin Kevin Kevin get away from that
lady she's going to by proxy that's
right
oh my god that was so much fun Christina
thank you so much for sitting with this
is there anything anything you want the
gang to know out there sure
Aiko's podcast guys we [ __ ] with
Corrine Fisher it's available on
luminary and very very happy and proud
about that one that's got a lot of fun
episodes in the log and I am my own solo
podcast called the voices in our heads
that's just me available everywhere and
I have a short film that just came out
called dwell that I wrote and star in
and with a bunch of other comics I'm
very proud of it so I saw it it's
awesome you're great congratulations
very good job thank you my yeah my
social media is at Kristina hutch its k
ry st Lyon
and that's we can find the links to
everything guys if for some reason you
don't follow her which I'm sure if you
listen to this you do please check out
all of Christina's project she's
absolutely killing it we appreciate you
coming in and and sitting with this
buddy Kippy what do you got for him just
again please make sure you rate review
subscribe share with a friend as we you
know get this puppy off the ground here
full video available on YouTube you can
subscribe and comment there will
interact with you that whole all that
biz and all I'm all on social media at
Kevin Ryan comedy on all very nice H
Foley on iced on Twitter at Foley
Graham's on Instagram again Kristina
thank you so much kitty kitty great a
great great time with both of you two
kids bye Kevin
he's seeping yeah he's very tired see
kitty that's a nice little puppy doggy
door guys thank you so much to listen
and hot you the best I appreciate you
buddy